this smartphone space is
ruthlessly competitive background how
did you get into all of a sudden wanting
to have so much interest into tech
i can remember running around my house
as a little kid with like an old vcr
camera just taking videos of stuff just
because it was fun
at what point were you telling yourself
you know i think i'm up to something
special here
there was no youtube partner program
nobody made money from this nobody's
full-time job was being a youtuber
unlike today so i didn't really start
this with aspirations of i think i can
make it i think this can be a thing
how does somebody compete with apple
how do you beat those guys but they've
built up products great products
that are tied to the iphone i'm wearing
an apple watch right now at the end of
the day
there's a lot of people already in
apple's ecosystem
everyone's gonna try to play catch-up
you gotta get ahead on something that's
obviously easier said than done
and then there's more competition the
more competition you and i win the most
i'm talking next three to five years do
you think there could be somebody that
beats these guys
well the people who are trying to fix
apple's problems are gonna go
work for apple most of the time so
so you're giving zero hope to everybody
else in the marketplace
it is tough to i mean you look at a two
trillion dollar company it is gonna be
really hard in a short term
do you think smartphones are gonna be
around forever do you think a product is
gonna come out that's gonna replace
smartphones well that's the billion
dollar questions
what's next
[Music]
my guest today is the number one tech
youtuber with over 13 million
subscribers he's interviewed elon musk
bill gates
kobe bryant i think in a 26 democratic
debate that was taking place
he even asked questions from the
candidates about the future of
technology
with that being said marcus brownlee
thank you so much for being a guest on
the entertainment
hey thanks for having me excited to be
here so how's it feel i'm in 30 million
subscribers i mean you're going out you
can't
get go to the airport without people
recognizing your face you know it's
funny it's not too bad
because they're all tech people and if
you know anything about nerds we stay
inside a lot so i i can get i can get
out
i can i can live a normal life and it's
actually not too bad
very cool very cool well you're you're
not a full-on
you're a cool nerd because you're also a
professional athlete right you also do
you know uh professional frisbee
and uh uh you know you've done you've
done great work for yourself you know i
want to take a couple angles with this
interview today
one is my eight-year-old and my
seven-year-old came up to me saying they
want to start a youtube channel okay and
they got this title and all the stuff
they want to talk about i started
youtube at 34 years old i don't know
what it is to be in high school saying
or to be in school saying i want to be a
youtuber when i grew up i think when you
started youtube you were
14 years old i think you were 14 years
old when you first started uploaded your
first video 08 or 09
right and then it led to what it is
today and then we'll talk about
smartphones as well so let's first talk
about
the smartphone side before we talk about
the youtube side
so background how did you get into all
of a sudden wanting to have so much
interest into tech
yeah i mean so as far as i as long as i
can remember i've been into tech so i
my dad is in i.t but i mean i can
remember running around my house as a
little kid with like an old vcr camera
just taking videos of stuff just because
it was fun
um i remember starting my channel it was
when i was getting into high school i
needed
a laptop to do schoolwork to make
powerpoint presentations write essays
and stuff so
my natural reaction to that was i'm
gonna go on youtube and watch as many
videos as i can of all the different
laptops as my own research to spend my
precious allowance money
and figure out what i should get and i
did and i watched all these videos and
they were all great
and i settled on one and i bought it and
when i got it
i started to notice things that i didn't
see in any of the videos
nobody was talking about and so for
whatever reason the natural reaction to
myself this
tech enthused you know high school kid
was to turn the camera on myself
literally the webcam
and just show those things that i didn't
see in the videos just in case you know
someone else in my position buying a
laptop could
see that stuff you know uh so that was
the first video it's just about the
the media center remote that comes with
the laptop and
yeah it was just you know found a couple
people here and there i said oh nice
video what
what about this other thing what about
the keyboard what about the you know
this other thing for it i i did a video
on the cooler i bought for it
and then the mouse i bought for it and
then the keyboard i bought for it
and then the software i was using on it
and then slowly it just became this
little community and
it slowly snowballed from there and you
know 1400 videos later here we are
when did you have when did you know
where you said i think this thing can
really pop
at what point were you telling yourself
you know i think i'm up to something
special here
it's a it's a good question i never
really know how to answer that because
it
it when i started like you mentioned
this was 2009. so
there was no youtube partner program
nobody made money from this nobody's
full-time job was being a youtuber
unlike today so i didn't really
start this with aspirations of i think i
can make it i think this can be a thing
really it was just like having fun on
the side as a hobby like so many other
high school kids have hobbies
and but i will say a lightbulb moment
for me was
uh you know somewhere in those first
like two or three years
i made a video about safari apple's web
browser when it became available for
windows for the first time
uploaded that just like every other
video went to sleep woke up the next day
and i think it had
like a few thousand views which at the
time was more than the number of
subscribers that i had so this was
clearly reaching
people who had never even you know
subscribed to my channel
and that to me was oh you know what
people really care about this timely
useful information i want to be as
informative as i can with this type of
stuff let me keep going with it
very cool when did you hit 100 000 subs
that i would have to look back i don't
actually remember um i remember when i
hit a thousand
uh which was about the first two years
and i remember when i hit 100
which was after the first 78 videos
which probably took about three to four
months
that's so interesting you say that
because i remember hitting a thousand
and it was after a couple years you know
it's
it seems like the the bigger number is
less important than the smaller number
because the smaller number
almost seemed tougher than the bigger
number if that makes any sense
i think it does i think you see a lot of
uh a lot of momentum
once you once you get to the bigger
numbers so the difference between a
hundred thousand and two hundred
thousand doesn't feel the same as
a hundred to two hundred you know yeah
that's a that's a
a good point there so question for you
about phones so for me
you know i saw the other day iphone came
out with a new thing they announced that
any small app companies with revenues
less than a million dollars they're
going to lower
the 33 percent to i think the number was
10 or 15 percent
and you know anybody above a million
dollars are still keeping the third so
if you do
10 million on apps they want to keep the
3.3 million dollars and you keep the 6.7
million dollars
and we were sitting and having a
conversation on the podcast and uh
i sat there and i said look what a great
net apple has created
if you want music you got to go through
itunes if you want to download an app
you pretty much got to go through itunes
if you want to do
you know group text and put a thumbs up
and you're droid i'm not
you know i'm apple you can't get the
thumbs up right and
if you want to you know send a a
group text sometimes even in a group
text a droid on an iphone
the group doesn't go out if you want to
do there's so many different things that
you look at with the net that they've
done
my biggest concern becomes as i look at
the market share i pulled this up you're
the expert yeah i'm curious to know what
you think about it
2020 q3 market share u.s i have usn have
worldwide in front of me worldwide it's
a different story
but in us apple's got 40
by the way q2 sales was 46
and samsung was 25 so if you look at the
numbers it's
relatively 46 percent 25
samsung 12 lg then it's seven percent
lenovo
then it's 10 others right so you got
huawei and whatever other phones that
may be
you know minus the sanction that they
have you go worldwide
samsung's at the top so i'm not going
worldwide i'm going specifically in the
u.s
how does somebody compete
with apple and smartphone in the us
how do you take market share away from
them i mean they have you
type in so i mean you're locked in you
got to have an iphone
how do you beat those guys yeah you know
they've they've built up
i did a video about this called just the
ecosystem they've built up
not just the iphone which has obviously
a pretty big head start on a lot of
other people trying to get market share
but they've built up
products that are great products that
are
tied to the iphone i'm wearing an apple
watch right now in my opinion it's the
best smart watch you can buy
it's only available if you have an
iphone airpods are some of the most
popular headphones on earth
that you can only really get the most
value out of if you use an iphone
and it just keeps going and going their
other products they all tie into this
ecosystem
and so it turns out if you want to
compete with apple
on market share of the phone you have to
compel
not just people to switch to your phone
but people to switch to your ecosystem
of products
that are tied to the phone which they're
all starting to do you know you see
other wireless headphone competitors you
see other
services competitors some even do things
that apple doesn't do like when you look
at google's pixel line you start to see
google photos integration you start to
see other google services plugged in
more tightly
but at the end of the day there's a lot
of people already in
apple's ecosystem who even if they could
switch for free
probably wouldn't because they're just
so happy with the products that they've
all tied in
um so it's tough you got it you got to
really make a compelling
series of reasons for them to switch to
a bunch of other products instead of
just
getting rid of the iphone because
getting rid of the iphone means getting
rid of a lot of stuff
which one of the which one of the nets
or which one of the
parts elements of the ecosystem do you
think
locks in the most users you think it's
the apps you think it's more the
hardware you know like the
the watch what do you think it is that
locks us into into apple
in the us it's definitely imessage uh
and i see this
uh as far like if i put my sim card in
an iphone i
carry an iphone specifically because i
have imessage only contacts people who
just use imessage
uh it's not so much the case worldwide
if you look at like you mentioned all
the
other areas they buy phones just based
on the hardware like huawei is gigantic
sure in china because people don't
necessarily care about the iphone's
hardware and imessage is
not really useful to them so in the us
it's for sure imessage
uh then i think you might see some pull
from like just hardware accessories
you know the the headphones the the
cases the apps
uh the app store is obviously a huge one
but i think it's imessage here
so so if let's just say samsung was to
hire you as a consultant
let's just say google hired you let's
say some of these guys hired you as a
consultant
and said marcus look you're you're a
student of this business
you you know this world this is all you
study your
tech guy that's been you know you're the
market share we want to go after as well
you're 26 years old you're somebody that
knows this very well
what can we do to beat apple in the next
36 to
60 months three to five years what angle
should we take what will be number one
product
then two then three what do you suggest
we do
yeah man i mean uh free advice is tough
but
you know what i would say is you you got
to get ahead on something because
everyone's going to try to play catch up
with what apple's been doing and apple
is a market leader in a lot of ways
they do something like remove the
headphone jack and what do you see two
years later everyone else goes oh yeah
we can make a great wireless set of
headphones and remove the headphone jack
you got to get a head on something
that's obviously easier said than done
you can just say get ahead but what do
you do
um and i think to me that all just comes
down to trying to make the best possible
product
and this is what i focus on my videos is
how good is the product really
for you and i buy for you and i to use
and if you can come up with something
that's
better objectively better about your
product
that can be a sort of a vaulting point
for for your marketing and for your
messaging and for your ecosystem to be
built around
but like i said that's a lot easier said
than done especially in 2020
something that's better would you would
you start with where apple's strongest
or would you start where apple is
weakest then
because again for me let me let me give
you my concern
here's my my concern and
where i'm coming from with this so for
example for me i think the best thing
that happened to the consumer
uh in regards to starbucks is coffee
bean
it's the dunkin donuts coffee is the
mcdonald's coffee
it's any of these guys that are coming
out with different kind of coffee
they're taking market share away from
starbucks what that does is
forces starbucks to get better and then
there's more competition the more
competition you and i win the most right
yeah so do you think there can be a
moment where somebody ends up beating
these guys in a
in the obviously term 40 50 years we may
not even be using phones
i'm talking next three to five years do
you think there could be somebody that
beats these guys
uh i would say the chances are slim
mainly because
you don't just talk about ideas it's the
it's the talent that
decides okay i just graduated from
engineering school i want to work for
the the best
r d company in the world where am i
going to go
and the companies that are already ahead
have the most pull so if you're
a younger or a smaller company who's
like i want to attack apple where it
hurts i want to beat them on the thing
they're not good at so i get their
customers
well the people who are trying to fix
apple's problems are gonna go
work for apple most of the time so it's
double hard for you to pull
employees and talent from them and then
beat them at what they're not so good at
they're always going to be trying to fix
that stuff too
so so you're giving zero hope to
everybody else in the marketplace
it is tough to i mean you look at a 2
trillion company it is gonna be really
hard in a short term
time to beat them but like you said
maybe in 40 50 years maybe in 10 years
we're not thinking about smartphones
nearly the same way so if you can get
ahead of that curve that's probably a
much better chance
so so so 15 years ago we're not going to
sit around
talking about smartphone 15 years ago
i'm using a blackberry net
nextel walkie-talkie which i thought was
going to be around forever hey johnny
i'm outside can you open the door hey uh
mom i'm here
oh my gosh you scared me you know all
that stuff that we i don't know if you
had to watch one of those walkie-talkie
next style stuff
you may have been younger too to have
one of those but uh
you know if you would have told me i
remember the first time a guy sat in
front of my
uh uh office and i'm selling him a
policy
and he's selling me on why i ought to
get away from blackberry to an iphone it
was iphone 2 at that time or three
i said i'm not going to apple he says
give me five minutes
if i convince you switch now he doesn't
work for apple he's just a guy that's
proud to be an apple user right
so he starts showing me stuff says give
me your phone let me show you this he
goes
by the time it's done i'm like why would
i not switch away from apple ii
from blackberry to an apple right so if
that
revolutionized the game smartphones
if every time we've had some kind of a
thing that's gotten us to get away from
what we were using before
do you think smartphones are going to be
around forever do you think a product is
going to come out that's going to
replace smartphones
yeah that is that's the million dollar
that's the billion dollar question is
what's
next after smartphones for me i feel
like i don't know if i'm
just short-sighted but i always feel
like there's going to be
a thing that we can pick up
and use and then put down and stop using
but i i think i realize that that's a
little bit short-sighted because i feel
like a lot of the next
wave of tech is so much more immersive
that you're just in it all the time
now whether that's a vr ar experience or
a or a microchip implanted
in the back of your head or something
like that or you've got these contact
lenses with tech in them
i think it's going to be a little more
than just an object that you pick up and
put down like we
call a smartphone today um but there's a
whole bunch of questions about like how
far off is that
when will that be good enough to pull
people away from the smartphone
experience that we all know and love
will it be a generational thing you know
people who are much older than us
never really got on the smartphone wave
people our age might never really get on
the next wave
right so there's a whole bunch of other
variables that have to do with that
transition but i think
for my short-sided mind it's a thing
that i
that i use and then stop using yeah that
you know i sat down with
the founder of lululemon and he said
in in 20 years no one's going to care
that you're in shape because everyone's
going to be in shape
i said what do you mean he says in the
next 20 years
everyone's going to be wearing smart
clothes i said tell me what you mean by
smart clothes
he says clothes that are going to tell
you don't eat that when you eat this
your blood pressure goes up you know
when you're
getting into an argument when someone's
pissing you off when you're around this
person you get more uncomfortable your
anxiety goes higher
he says smart clothes is going to make
all of us be healthier 20 years from now
that's not going to be a big deal
anymore so it's something to be thinking
about
smart phones smart clothes but
in your eyes what is your favorite phone
to use
uh if you i know you have a droid and
you have an uh apple
what is your favorite phone to use
between the two and why
i mean i this year 2020 we saw a lot of
weird
phones and i'm making a video about like
these alternate form factors but here's
what i'll say
the iphone you get two or three new
models a year
and you kind of know what you're going
to get it's going to be a little bit
different from the last one a little
faster
a little bit better photos a little bit
better screen
in the android world i mean we had the
galaxy fold fold in half we had the lg
wings swivel out like this
we had we have you know candy bar phones
like i carry in my my sim cards in a
oneplus 8 pro
came out about a year ago it's my daily
phone but what i say is my
favorite to use daily it's
it's fine it works uh but there's just
so much more
variety and competition in within that
android world that breeds all kinds of
interesting stuff
that i think is my favorite to observe
now i think eventually apple will get
into that sort of
alternate form factor market and i'm
excited for that but if i were to pick
one right now i'd probably say something
like the galaxy fold 2
which would earn my most improved award
for smartphones this year
so so why why do you use a droid over an
apple i mean why do you why do you use a
a droid as a day-to-day use more than an
iphone and by the way i'm curious the
droid what is the service are you with
atn t
t-mobile verizon who are you with yeah
uh i've got att
uh yes i you know not super tied to them
but they work for now
um and i use this as my main phone
because of the customization
uh that i am just a i'm a tech fan i
just i enjoy
setting up and changing my experience
every once in a while some people just
change their wallpaper
some people change their icon pack and
the color theme and all kinds of other
stuff i'm one of those people so
i get a lot of fun uh every few months
switching it up on android
um you can do that a little more on ios
now which is fun but it's sort of
a workaround kind of a hacked way so
it's not perfect yet but
that's the main reason i think i enjoy
my android phone so much
also if i put my sim card from my
android phone into my iphone
imessage is notorious for just
swallowing up all of your texts
and if you take that sim card back out
of the iphone
and put it back into the android phone
most people who do that
start missing text messages because
imessage continues
to to grab texts um so i don't think
i'll ever
you know consolidate to one sim i think
i will probably always have an iphone
sim and an android sam for that reason
uh marcus what phone numbers do you give
to people on your iphone what phone
numbers you give to people on your
i mean how do you how do you mix the two
up or does family have both numbers
i it is sort of a um a mess
i give most people my android phone
number because that's what i've had the
longest
and i have some family and some contacts
that have my imessage number
uh just because they were sending videos
or whatever family group
chat reason there was uh but yeah the
number i've had since high school is my
android phone number that's the one 90
something percent of my contacts have
but it's
is pretty comp i don't know how to
choose which one to give someone
if they're sending me a video iphone
right but if they're just calling me
maybe my
main phone unless it's business and i
don't it's a lot
there you go well that's why i said i
think about what
so then there would need to be a
question what kind of a phone do you use
iphone let me give you this phone number
here what kind of a phone you use droid
let me give you my droid phone number
here that would be the only way i would
process it
on how to do them by the way you know i
went to verizon for at one point like
seven years ago i switched to verizon
i've been with atnt for quite some time
now
you know what brought me back from
verizon to at t just because i
couldn't merge calls with verizon
with a tnt i can have six people on the
call together
i can tell six people call myself merge
merge
merge merge merge i can't do that with
verizon
so at t allows me to merge six calls
verizon only allows me to do three ways
with two other people
so i don't know if that was an
endorsement for a tnt or not but if
you're running a business
a a uh you know being able to get on the
phone with five six guys rather than
having to set up a conference call and
all that other stuff is a little bit
easier to use so
question a little bit of a different
question for you sure let's just say
one morning a guy who
used to live in california and i lived
in austin texas
wakes up and he's bored out of his mind
okay and this happens to him quite a lot
and he wakes up and he says you know
what
i've been in the most competitive space
for a long time and i'm competing with
everybody
and the company i built is called tesla
right
and you know kind of gone to space i've
blown up a few things here and there but
i've been pretty successful during a
good time in a limited budget
and it's kind of cool i started a
company called the boring company
what about if i decided to go and
screw with everybody and start a
smartphone company
could i compete with everybody else out
there my name is elon musk
huh okay so i've heard a lot of
uh you know could uh could one of these
companies start a smartphone especially
tesla tesla makes batteries could tesla
make an incredible smartphone with great
battery
and my initial thought is yeah of course
don't why would i ever doubt elon
and him with startup of course he could
probably pull it off
but the other hand uh is
this smartphone space especially in the
top you know bit of
of of of market share as we were
describing earlier
is ruthlessly competitive now of course
the auto industry was ruthlessly
competitive before tesla came along but
tesla came along with a new technology
that it's going to take them years to
catch up to
and i don't know if there is a new
technology that smartphone makers aren't
considering or haven't already tried to
start working on
that someone could just leap in and
dominate at
smartphones are trying all kinds of
stuff
you know when you look at the new
highest end phones it does seem very
consistent the same high-end screens and
cameras and everything
but i was just talking about the folding
phones the swiveling phones
the new battery tech we see all this
wireless tech
all this stuff is getting better at a
very high rate and if you're going to
just jump in there
there's another company called red that
i'm a big fan of that makes incredible
cameras
and they decided they were going to jump
in and make a smartphone a couple years
ago
and i thought okay yeah red could make a
phone and their advantage would be the
camera
and they made a terrible phone and it
died
before the year was over so i
i don't know that you can just jump in
and immediately start competing for the
top end of market share you can make
something interesting
but i think i think it would be pretty
tough see the difference between red
and tesla would be
no one knows the founder of red except
for people in the world
everybody knows the founder of tesla and
tesla likes to do things when you tell
him he can't do it you know the guy elon
you know him you've interviewed him
before you've been to his plant before
you've seen what he's done
and he prefers that he likes that and i
think in your interview you said what
the
f the number one car he posted in an
article he talked about it the number
four number one car where people
switch over to tesla is what a prius so
24 000 card that they switch over to
the tesla and you ask them a question
whether you guys gonna be able to come
out with a cheaper car and he said maybe
three years because
manufacturing being able to keep up with
orders etc etc
you know if you were to say ecosystem
wise
you know apple is pulling from their app
their imessage their other hardware the
phone
watch you just showed who has an
ecosystem to be able to pull into having
a phone would it be a tesla would it be
a facebook would it be an amazon
who would it be that has an additional
product already to say
here's what we already do we're going to
come up with a phone
and if you use us we're going to give
you an extra experience on dot dot dot
right yeah that is really interesting i
so amazon did try uh making a phone
didn't go great but you would think so
amazon's got aws they've got the amazon
store they've got their own app store
they've got amazon music
that's a good start that you could kind
of tie in i don't know if anyone's
compelled to switch
from their iphone because of amazon
music or something like that but if they
could make some
cool exclusives with the amazon.com
store
maybe that's something but i think what
i found is the most compelling reasons
to switch are actually
just great hardware so if you could make
a great
smartphone accessory and i don't know i
don't think a
tesla is gonna be that smartphone
accessory but if you can make a great
uh accessory that is amazing hardware
and works
best when you have your phone and not
the iphone
that becomes a reason to switch because
you know all of apple services are fine
imessage is fine apple's mail service is
fine
safari is fine i'm not you know looking
for a reason to switch web browser i can
use chrome on the iphone whatever but if
you have like
these incredible headphones and you need
to have
this phone to be able to use this
amazing headphone experience and apple
doesn't offer that
maybe that's the reason but out of
today's existing companies like you just
mentioned like tesla amazon
whoever hasn't made a phone facebook i
think even tried to make a phone and it
was also terrible
so it's clearly tough it's competitive
but uh i think it would take some sort
of a
missing link hardware type stuff i guess
we'll see what's going to happen there
the best thing about it is the fact that
competition always breeds innovation and
someone who wants to compete in the
marketplace we're going to see a new
product coming out so we just talked
about the u.s market world market is a
complete different story it's not even
close by when you look at the world
market
uh market share worldwide q3 i'll just
give you q3 samsung's got 23 percent
okay they shipped at 80 million phones
uh huawei's got 14.9 they shipped at
51.7 million phones
xiaomi i don't even know how to
pronounce that got 13 and a half percent
they shipped at 47 million
apple's fourth at 12.4 percent they
shipped at 43 million and then
vivo is 9.1 percent they shipped that 32
million
phones q3 this is how many phones are
being sold
how does the world outside of u.s
because what we know is
apple apple apple apple apple iphone
iphone
how does the world view apple versus
samsung versus us in the us because
we're obviously very impressed with
apple but how do they view it
yeah there's a couple a couple
differences i think between the us
market and the world market
that kind of dictate this market share
difference we see one is the u.s market
is very carrier-driven and so if you're
going to get
your phone into people's pockets you
need to first get your phone into the
carrier's hands and give them a reason
to sell it and but you have to you have
to have a good relationship with the us
carriers
uh worldwide people very much buy
unlocked phones they'll they'll move
their sim card physically between phones
they don't depend on carriers nearly as
much so they're buying more just based
on
what hardware they can get um the other
thing is
the us is if you kind of think of it as
like bubbles
is one of the big smartphone markets the
other huge smartphone market is asia and
china specifically and that's where you
see
xiaomi and huawei you pronounce it right
by the way that's where you see them
massive and because their their share in
china is so high
their overall global share is so high
but then there's a european market and
that's a little bit of a different taste
a little bit of a different mix um
so you you don't necessarily just get to
dominate worldwide market share you sort
of have to approach each market
differently
and almost run a different style of
company in each of these markets to
to get that market share so apple's
challenge is the chinese market and
xiaomi's challenge is the u.s market
do you know any of these guys that are
not like for example
huawei's not in u.s and when they were
banned from being in u.s with the whole
political thing that took place
you know everybody looked at huawei as i
never used huawei right but huawei
is got a massive market share they're
very innovative they're very creative
they're very
uh competitive at what they're doing do
you know anything
these phone companies outside the us are
doing that is absolutely revolutionary
that we're not doing in the us or is
everything pretty much same as huge
business as usual
i think it's it's still very competitive
so you see a lot of the great stuff
but what i did say when i reviewed
huawei's two latest phones this year
uh i'm in the us i'm getting these
phones imported
they half the services don't work
they're incredibly incomplete and i
would never recommend buying them here
but i said in those videos those are the
best phones that you shouldn't buy
because their hardware is excellent
their screens the dramatic waterfall
displays
their camera systems on the back are
easily top five
in the world i mean their battery life
is great
they have this crazy fast wireless
charging technology you just don't
really see in many other phones
so the hardware innovation is happening
everywhere
but you just don't recommend buying a
huawei phone
and importing it to the us to use those
couple of fringe
features even if they are super advanced
and eventually those features will make
it into the rest of
their competition so i don't know if
there's anything dramatic we're totally
missing out on here in the us but there
is some really good stuff here
that's thriving in other markets that
we're just not really buying
cool uh question for you about iphone
you know a lot of times when
the new iphone comes out and i don't
know if this is me i've read about it
different places and a lot of our agents
have brought this up to my attention
it seems like every time a new iphone
comes out the older models
they get glitchy they get slower you
know
like you're thinking is is apple trying
to piss you off to say i'm just gonna go
buy the new iphone
or you know is it just a
you know a frustrating evolution of a
phone that's getting older man i have a
lot of feelings about this
and uh some of them are some of them i
know are grounded in fact
and some of them i'm just i just have
feelings about so
i find it very hard to believe that a
company would
willingly degrade their own products
in order to get you to hopefully buy the
next one
i just found that so i don't i don't
know why i just i find it difficult to
believe
uh now we we do have the concrete
factual evidence
that apple goes all right listen
batteries when they get older
they cannot supply the same voltage to
the parts
safely so what we'll do is when the
phones get one year old
we'll bump down the cpu clock speed a
little bit so that the battery
with its current level of health cannot
have any problems with that clock speed
now what does that translate to cpu just
got slower everyone just sees apple
makes your phone
slower after a year well there it is
right apple's making your phone slower
to get you to buy the new one right
and so they have this excuse well we're
volting it down because we're
saving you your battery life so your
phone lasts longer and is better over
time what would you rather have a little
slower clock speed or a dead battery
but it's it's really easy to take the
the cynical
apple wants you to buy the new one every
year route
mentally and i think a lot of people
just see that and
and we'll run with that so i don't know
it's uh
it's a i think if it's a bit of a mix
and i think there's a really great quote
that for every smart man's decision
there is the right answer and the real
answer
and i think for apple they have a right
which is oh yes we're protecting your
battery life and they have a real answer
which is
you know if your phone does get too slow
you can pay us
to make it faster for a battery
replacement or just buy a new phone
so it's a little bit of both i tell you
what they're they're
uh they're brilliant but do you think
it's ever gonna get to a point where the
apple thing cause you know apple users
have always been very
uh they've gotten criticism of being
cult-like and you know it's it's uh
emotionally attached to it do you think
it's ever gonna get to a point where a
product a a company like apple can
piss off customers to say you know what
the hell with this
we're on strike we're leaving you you
think it's ever going to get there is
the emotional attachment
to apple so tight that guys are going to
get through it and they're going to say
they're just going through some hiccups
right now i'm going to stay loyal to
them
i think they've tested those waters i
think they have every year
they've they've done some things where
you would go you know how could i
not leave uh i think they're you know
you call it emotional attachment there's
some of that
and they make genuinely great products
so a lot of people will buy them and use
them and enjoy them
but uh yeah you know there's there's
stuff like the
the charging on the the magic mouse
being like you have to flip it upside
down and can't use it just weird design
decisions like that where you go
am i really going to switch out of this
whole ecosystem
because i don't like that one little
thing
probably not the switch cost is actually
pretty high and then the other thing is
apple's a huge company with tons of
talented people and engineers and
a decision so bad that it would drive
people away
would have a very hard time making it
all the way to the top of the ladder and
actually showing up in a product so
i think they've they've they've pushed
those but
those borders a little bit and found
where they are see
what i wonder is do they sit in a room
when they're looking at that mouse
with smartest developers on r d guys
saying
dude just put it on the side so it's not
going to be that difficult and then
somebody says
no let's piss them off because apple
users like it to be a little bit more
difficult
put it on the bottom to piss them off
they're going to like it even more
i made a video about when apple made so
you know the mac pro their desktop tower
pc and they made those wheels for it
and they charged seven hundred dollars
for four wheels with no brakes
for a computer that's plugged into the
wall
and i thought that is maybe the
stupidest product anyone could ever
operate and completely like make and
think they could logically sell but you
know what i think there's a little part
of apple
that sees the meme ability of a luxury
company like that because
they're high end in pretty much
everything they attack and i think they
do make some decisions where it's like
you know what this is the way we want it
and you're gonna like it and you know
they made those 550
headphones not too long ago that have
some other questionable decisions with
that case and i think it's just like
they've got some designers that just see
it a certain way and
you're just gonna have to just deal with
that part you got
you gotta love them for it though you
know that that's gotta be a part of the
dna of the founder
yeah there's got to be a dna that's
found i remember i interviewed steve
steve uh wozniak in 2010
at an event that had him over and i i
surprised him with the original computer
that he had built and you should have
seen the look on his face when we
brought it to him and we
put it on his lap and he's like a kid in
a candy store and then he's signing
it so we're gonna give it away to
somebody and
you ask questions why did you guys do
certain things that was just out of
whack and
different you know and and they almost
had a chip on their shoulder to say
we're going to build the best product
you're going to love it we're going to
do it our way
you know whether you like it or not
we're going to do it better than other
guys so
very interesting story i wonder if
that's some of tim cook's stuff or
that's more of steve jobs
culture coming down to apple i think a
little bit too is the design
team like the johnny johnny is not with
apple anymore but that design part like
i talked about the headphone jack before
and how they have this vision of getting
to a portless phone and for whatever
reason that's this vision they have we
want to get to a portless
holeless phone and eventually they'll
get rid of that lightning port and
everyone will go
what are you doing apple getting rid of
the port on the phone
but there's something to i mean apple
has if any company can start that
it's apple um but yeah there's just a
little a little dna from
those those core people at the company
yeah marcus are you somebody that
studied steve jobs or no you're not
somebody that
studies personalities you're more
studies products i
i def i don't know if i'd say studied
but i'm definitely fascinated with the
best
communicators in the world and i think
steve was definitely one of the best
communicators
ever uh and so i'm fascinated by that um
now the way he runs the company is
something else to study and the way that
he
invents things that he wants to exist is
another thing but
yeah i think the the communication part
of it is what interests me
what do you think about tim cook tim
cook is
is fine i don't have any like strong
thoughts on tim and he's
he's clearly running apple well that
ship is like a well-oiled machine at
this point i think he came from the
logistics
side of that company and the that's
going great
um but i i don't know if he has the same
i don't know if anyone has the same
charisma on stage as steve jobs
explaining why this is the way something
should happen so
uh it might be an unfair comparison but
yeah
i think he's done a great job i'm a fan
of tim cook and i think he had a very
very tough uh
uh you know nobody wanted that job just
think about it you're about to replace
the man and you're gonna go do this
and typically when somebody replaces a
guy with that big of a personality
they last for a year and a half two
years they get fired and then they bring
a new person and then people compare
them
not to steve they compare them to the
ceo that got fired which is a little bit
of an easier job
but it's very impressive what uh tim's
been able to do it so
these were great questions the great
answers you gave to uh
uh the topics we covered with uh
smartphones let's go into youtube so
you know nowadays i i uh went to school
and they were asking questions
and on survey came back
that the top thing the kids wanted to do
in
the grade level they're in eight and
seven year olds they want to be
youtubers when they grow up
when you were in high school at 14 um
and you started your youtube channel how
many other kids in school were also
youtubers like you
definitely definitely none absolutely
none and did you go to a big school or
was it a small school in jersey
oh public uh pretty big school uh
yeah thousands of kids no nobody else
making as far as i knew
no one else was making youtube videos uh
i have no idea what the top job was back
then
now that i think about it but it
definitely wasn't youtube
crazy crazy and what would you say today
like let's just say so that was 14
12 years ago so what if today you were
and you wanted to do youtube start a
youtube channel versus
in 2008 2009 would your approach
at all change today versus dinner would
have been the same approach
that is tough so i get asked a lot
what would my like advice be to someone
starting today
and i always feel so bad because i don't
really have
a good answer youtube is very different
today
than it was 12 years ago right the scale
is different
the discoverability of something new is
different the saturation of every niche
is different
so when i was starting i wasn't starting
with any sort of strategy
to make it there was no partner program
for
for years i made zero dollars in the
first however many years i started
but it was more just about this like
community thing this fun
building process and learning production
and and
tech enthusiasts and that's just kind of
all it was um
if you were starting today you would
kind of need
a strategy um to get away from
you know just making videos for fun if
you want to turn it into a job
you need a you need a content strategy
you need a business plan you need all
the stuff and i just i just
don't have that i think my advantage was
12 years ago
there were nine tech channels on youtube
and it was easy to just pick one and
follow it
and now there's 9 000 of them good luck
right um so yeah i feel bad that i don't
have like a good answer for giving
advice to the
millions of kids who want to be a
professional youtuber but what i would
say
is if you do want to make youtube videos
pick a topic you enjoy
and just do it for fun and you have to
be happy doing it for fun
and imagine you'll never make a dime off
of it ever
would you still do it for fun if the
answer is yes go for it
if you're here to make money it's going
to take a lot more than just
doing it for fun marcus question for you
if you weren't going to go
the youtube route at 14 you didn't start
a youtube channel what would you be
doing today
i would probably be in some marketing
department
in some new york city tech company i
think when i
when i first went to college i was
studying communications but also
business and technology and information
systems and i think i'd be somewhere in
one of those offices in new york city
emailing youtubers about reviewing
products i'd probably be on the other
side of the chair
so you'd be looking for guys like
yourself as well exactly
so you wouldn't go to engineer rod you'd
be more on the marketing sets it's
interesting because uh uh uh you never
had an itch for engineering at all was
it always storytelling and marketing
i had a little bit i mean i went to
stevens tech which is a great
engineering school and i
started actually just as an information
systems uh
major which has a lot more software
engineering to it
um but i just i got a lot more out of
and i think it's still true today the
final product and how it affects the
person buying it that experience that
connection between the maker and the
buyer
so obviously all the behind the scenes
and engineering stuff is cool but i
i just wanted to just figure out why the
final product was any good or not so
i think i'd be somewhere in that that
channel
and today what are some of your youtube
channels that you follow
do you follow other tech uh you know
youtube channels
you know do you follow certain stories
out there that you see and i really like
what
this vlogger is doing or i really like
what this personality is doing
who are some of the channels you
followed today oh yeah i would it would
take me forever to name them all but i
i mostly watched youtube at this point i
have a netflix account
i don't remember the last time i logged
in i i mainly just watched youtube
really yeah and a lot of my friends are
creators so i watch their videos so it's
like
in the tech world there's obviously a
lot there's friends like justine
and john morrison and juddner your
average consumer lou
unbox therapy names you might have heard
of names your kids might have heard of
then there are the you know the vloggers
the casey neistats of the world there
are the cinematographers the peter
mckinnons of the world
uh there's the top gears of the world
too we've been doing a lot of car stuff
lately and i can't help but watch other
car videos to get ideas for
car shots and how to shoot those videos
um
but i don't there's just a lot i mean i
could go i could go down my sub box i
think i'm subscribed to like 400
channels or something at this point
do you look at other creators who are in
your space from a systematic standpoint
or do you look at it more from the
creative standpoint meaning do you say
okay their system of putting this video
together they first do this then they do
this then they do this then
i got their system this is how they do
this 10 videos they have the same system
they follow or do you say
wow look at the cinematic creative
lighting what what angle do you look at
them from
it's a little bit of both and it depends
on the creator so
if you look at like growing a channel
for example you look at some of the
fastest growing channels and see what
they're doing well one of my friends
jimmy
mr beast is i think he has 50 million
subscribers or somewhere near that at
this point and every time i watch one of
his videos i'm thinking
that's great for audience retention
that's great for growth and
discoverability and clickability
um i might watch uh yeah yeah i might
watch some peter mckinnon videos and
think oh that's a
that's just a great shot i just enjoy
that shot
um and there's even other threads about
like communicating
and and explaining technology that i'll
learn from other channels there's a
great channel uh called quartzkazart and
all they do is explain things
and that's really hard to do at a high
level is explain things like
consciousness and the universe and the
scale of our solar system
and they do a great job so it depends on
who i watch but you gotta pay attention
to all of it yeah
i gotta share this vid you know my plan
is to share this video my kids so they
can kind of get some ideas because they
are
so excited right now about wanting to do
something um
for starters for a kid to get started
with a youtube channel even a teenage
somebody getting started
with a youtube channel what tools do i
need can i just start off with just an
iphone
that is true if when i was starting in
you needed tools now if your kid has an
iphone
yet you're set you've got one of the
best you got a better camera than i had
when i started already
and what you also have is a little
editing machine in your pocket
with a little editing software and a
direct connection to youtube
so honestly yeah if you've got a great
topic if you've got
great charisma on something and you just
point the camera phone at yourself
and talk about it and you can edit that
that content is more important than the
quality of the video itself
that stuff can come with time you can
grow you can learn camera skills you can
buy a camera
you can buy more tools get better
editing but
the actual content of what you're
talking about matters more we're doing
this on a zoom call like no one's
watching this for the quality of it
but the actual contents itself so i
think yeah you can get started with an
iphone for sure
phenomenal well marcus i gotta tell you
i've really enjoyed this uh
your stud for what you're doing in your
space
uh anytime i am getting to a point where
i'm contemplating
uh the phone that i have i like to go to
your
your youtube channel say let's see what
marcus has got to say about it you've
done a great job with that
and you've stayed very what's the word
very neutral you know if you were a
political channel you'd be like none we
have today because you're right in the
middle you just kind of give your
opinions on what it is and it's very
hard
to keep a position like that you've done
a great job with that so i appreciate
you for coming on and being a guest
and sharing your insight we're going to
put the link below for people to be able
to go out there and find you on youtube
if they haven't seen you
but thank you for your time brother
thanks for having me on appreciate the
conversation
any time any time so what do you think
you think a tesla facebook and app
somebody can
come out and compete in a marketplace
and if yes who would it be can you
imagine if elon musk says
i want to compete in a smartphone space
what that would look like comment below
i'm curious to know who you think it
would be and also if you didn't see my
interview with steve wozniak years ago
you got to see his reaction when he gets
this computer that he built when we hand
it to him
his reaction is priceless click over you
to watch it
thanks so much for watching everybody
take care bye